f2
what else can you do now you take on g3
whatever
yeah i'll take you as a g rook i think
it's only one check yeah but it's
contour check
minimum yeah or just king g5
kg5 no more checks something will happen
it's true
g2 is a threat because you can give
knight and hulk and the queen you still
have a hook
chamber by f visibly very nervous but so
winning
would you be nervous
most likely yes why
i don't know
it's your opponent opponent factor
yeah no but here i mean it's too easy
but long game you know 10th world cup
probably i would be nervous here
but it's good to be a bit nervous you
know a lot
yes but on the other hand it also means
that
you haven't been in that situation often
before
i mean like beating one number two in
world cup
sure yeah okay what is it the third
round there so
still a bit too early to get excited
there
oh okay it's nice now to be in the first
one already yeah sure
already excellent result
fabi will may try to find some tricks
but
24 played by fabio g2 of course
king you won only no not only move king
one okey two you win king f1 you win
queen g2 knight g2 will see your
handshake and we saw it
draw af big upset
in the main section in the open section
i have just knocked out uh favela
caruana
one number two and then it is
actually first real match
as he had this incident with uh
the indonesian player meganto they only
played 15 moves and then
uh he had to forfeit
because of because of positive tests
well whatever congratulations to drama
bye f great great performance
[Music]
to beat fabi in a in a match of two
classical games
that's really amazing